uh-huh hey Taylor its Gary being on the
askgaryvee show no way yes we're okay
where are you from I'm from Buffalo New
York
I love are you Bills fan uh
unfortunately yes
all right I know you said I'm fortunate
very good I know well listen neither are
the Jets don't worry so what's going on
not much I basically would dying to ask
you a question
currently graduated college last May and
I'm trying to build my own business plan
hustle all that kind of stuff and my
question for you is and I'm probably
sure that a lot of people ask this there
are more exciting things
okay how do you get over the stump of
your graduating and you feel this
pressure because you're trying to build
something but you're still so young but
you want to do this fast and grow it big
and I'm just gonna write and I can't get
out of it but I have a hustle in the
drive that I know I'll be able to build
something but I'm just in this space so
no we're allowing me to so let me help
you the space you're in is probably the
macro micro issue so it's macro patience
micro speed right so what do I in by
that you need to be patient as [ __ ]
Taylor you're you're twenty-two
twenty-three years old
like what do you think is gonna happen
overnight yeah I know so you need to be
fast 7:00 a.m. to 2:00 in the morning
every day but in the big picture you
need to realize nothing good is gonna
happen for the next six years okay and
do you think that I should just try
every good idea that I think I have and
just go for it all out or do you think I
should stick with one thing at a time I
think the fact that you even asked that
question that you should taste flirting
with a lot of different things because
you'll be crippled by the what if if you
don't even though that's not the perfect
formula to build the biggest
short-term wealth because you should go
dip triple down on one thing instead of
being half pregnant online okay Taylor
let me tell you something you like let
me ask you the pressure chlorine like
are you trying to prove to yourself to
your siblings to your parents to the
world like who are you trying to prove
that you're successful to or that this
was the right call or you're gonna make
it like that's what you have to figure
out mmm what do you like what are you
impatient for like what's what's the
problem you want to buy a [ __ ] Rolex
like what's the what what's the rush I
feel like I've known that I'm meant to
do something big and it's over up in an
entrepreneurial house me too and so it's
in my blood it's in my bone and good and
I feel like I watch all these other
Millennials hitting these huge I guess
milestones in their life and then I sit
here let's break it down how old are you
I'm 22 all about to be 23 okay what
miles please give me a millennial and
the milestone they achieved that makes
you feel like you're just sitting in
[ __ ] Buffalo well I'm sitting in
Buffalo which is one thing I'm not happy
about that's right because it's on the
Buffalo Bills piece of [ __ ] team but you
have why but but but before you go there
forget about sitting in Buffalo who's
the Millennial and what's the milestone
that's making you feel like you're
sitting there go the truth go well
honestly there's people on social media
which definitely it's not always true
but I like okay I guess the only thing
on the spot I can think of is a
Kardashian or a Jenner who it's just
lame but can we talk about this and I
feel like sure like you're telling me
that Kylie Jenner's [ __ ] trillion
followers on Instagram makes you feel
like you're just sitting there no I feel
like the fact that she's already got a
business started that's super successful
you do fact do you fan did you factor in
the fact that her sisters and mom
architected something for ten years
while she was a teenager that she was
able to walk directly into that gay
her a springboard and that she had the
financial capabilities of deploying
ungodly amounts of you know plastic
surgery and the and all the other
variable things that she's been able to
do to create that culture and that
financial benefit yeah did you factor in
that her mom is a ninja architect of
business and created that framework yeah
and I feel like not many people give
them the credit for that I totally think
that I agree with this Empire I agree
but what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with you it has nothing to do with me I
know you remember how I I don't know if
you saw this where I said stop looking
at your friends [ __ ] or whatever [ __ ] I
put on Instagram yeah I don't know if
you saw it or not but it doesn't matter
what like you looking at the Kardashians
is the most ludicrous horseshit I've
ever heard in my life well that's the
first thing that could pop into my heart
right give me that
listen we're here we're here give me
another one um there's a guy in London I
can't explain it the most I'm gonna stop
you right now okay let me give you some
I was gonna say father I guess my father
was Ford and now I'll give you some
massively older brother uncle advice you
ready okay
yes every second you spend thinking
about what somebody else has is taking
away from time that you could create
something for yourself yeah you're
losing you're losing because you're
laying in your bed looking at somebody's
[ __ ] glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something cool and you're
envious and you're jealous and you're
impatient and it's crippling you're
upside yeah cuz that's where I want to
be and I know I'm not there yet you
haven't done [ __ ] I know so go do [ __ ]
that actually gets you there so that you
earn it instead of like you dwelling
that you're not there and hoping
something's gonna happen I don't know
what's going through your mind yeah well
I guess I'm hustling on the sides I
don't think I'm doing enough I guess you
definitely aren't doing enough if you
have enough time to [ __ ] consume the
content of a Kardashian and some boy in
London that's Kara
listen to me Taylor listen you've got to
deploy patience and you've got to love
the process I'm a
addicted to the process of the battle
scars the setbacks the lack of you know
Taylor I gave up my entire 20s all of
them imagine not doing anything fun or
going anywhere for the next eight years
including Saturday and Sunday that's
what I did from 22 to 30 every day I
spent 15 hours a day in a liquor store
thought about a liquor store built a
liquor store sold wine like spent every
day like this last weekend don't lie to
me Taylor what didn't you do this last
weekend what didn't you [ __ ] in front
Saturday and Sunday tell me the truth
don't [ __ ] me yeah no [ __ ] I'm
helping my mom right now on visual media
and branding for her company login so I
had a marketing meeting with one of the
people doing that love you and then I
also how much time did you have how much
how much time to be up for yourself on
Saturday and Sunday that was not working
every minute tell me the truth a lot a
lot I know so that's the punchline right
now imagine that yeah when I tell you
this you spent more downtime on not your
career this weekend then I did in my
entire 20s combined oh [ __ ] okay that
puts things into perspective I think so
laughter I think so - yeah I need to get
to it tell her you need to do me a huge
favor
if you really want to win and you want
to come to New York in eight years and
shake my hand here's what you need to do
you need to stop giving a [ __ ] about
what anybody else has and realized that
if you put your head down and just work
for the next ten years no glamour no new
[ __ ] car suitcase jewelry trip event
no Coachella no [ __ ] new [ __ ]
sneakers like [ __ ] work you will have
it and every time you care about one of
the things I just mentioned it will slow
down your process of having it okay so
in less than eight years when I'm a
millionaire by 25 I'll come shake your
hand I promise you that statement in
itself made me 100 percent guarantee
that you won't know yes that's how this
works being a millionaire twenty-five
hundred
- and you're a dick [ __ ] and haven't
even started it's inconceivable unless
you [ __ ] hit the lotto
what's the romance what's the romance of
I want to make you know how everybody
says Gary Vee wouldn't get by the Jets
in two years and then I replied twenty
years I'm a romantic about the journey
in the process which is why I'm actually
gonna pull it off you're trying to be a
millionaire by 25 how Taylor it's just a
goal I've always had one right now with
what I'm doing I guess it's not that's
right it's an arbitrary [ __ ] thing
that means nothing yeah
wouldn't you rather guarantee
millionaire ship by 36 than by by doing
long-term marathon running versus doing
a bunch of [ __ ] sprints that
guarantees never having it and I promise
you funny thing happens to your
self-esteem when you're 31 and not a
millionaire because you've been chasing
fast [ __ ] cash and you're now six
years removed from not hitting your goal
your self-esteem starts [ __ ] with
your head mm-hmm yeah listen carefully I
wanna I want to buy the New York Jets
but when I clarify it to everybody I
want the process of trying to buy the
New York Jets more than buying the New
York Jets understand yeah because
ultimately that's the end goal but
there's a process behind that you have
to understand I don't give a [ __ ] about
the end goal I care about the process
the enjoyment of doing it you're not
enjoying yourself trying to get to a
million bucks over the next three years
now really you're right
oh I know I'm right I'm just sticking on
this right now because I feel like we've
gone into this deep enough that I might
as well hold on for a couple more
minutes
to see if I could actually pull you
through instead of you just being on
this hi of practicality for 36 hours and
then going back to Instagram [ __ ] in
48 hours I mean if you activate that
[ __ ] no you need to learn the discipline
to be able to put it in the proper
bucket yeah I just feel like I hold
myself at this pedestal me it's
crippling myself because I'm not
actually doing the things to get there
of course so you're playing a fake
narrative instead of putting in the
actual work that's needed
actually pull it off wishing instead of
executing and then and then what's
happening is you're living a fake world
to yourself but you know it which then
changes your behavior and the way that
you interact with others okay
I know like for all my bravado now I was
real quiet in my 20s people made fun of
me like you work in your dad's liquor
store I'm in Wall Street making a
hundred thousand I got a BMW I'm like
that's nice Pat yeah do you understand
the level of disrespect I have for Pat
d-lab do you understand the level of
disrespect I have for all those 20 30 40
50 year olds flashing [ __ ] on [ __ ]
Instagram with short-term news I can't
wait for the [ __ ] world to melt I
can't wait for all these [ __ ] people
to get [ __ ] hosed out when the
economy gets [ __ ] yes because their
short term affording these things that
are flashy but in the long term it's not
sustainable for what they're doing right
now you have a mean while you're
admiring the [ __ ] out of them I know
it's a problem miss [ __ ] is really bad
Taylor you need to start [ __ ] love in
the process and the work and the grind
you need to start respecting people that
are like sleeping within like with four
roommates and buying their t-shirts at
Walmart yeah you know what I feel like I
need that wake up but I feel like I need
to hit rock bottom and just have that
wake up I'm too comfortable right now
and it's annoying that [ __ ] out of me I
don't I don't think so I think you are
saying you need to hit rock bottom
because it buys you more time to
[ __ ] like you are right now hmm I
never thought of that you know what I
mean like you know it's not working
you're just saying by the way let me go
complete left-field on you you're a 22
year old girl woman like it's okay to
enjoy a little bit now - you've heard me
say regrets if you I don't know how deep
you know my content but once in a blue
moon when people ask me the advice for
25 year old Gary the answer is go have
fun
[ __ ] it would've been okay to go to
Vegas or Acapulco or like like do some
dumb [ __ ] like do you know what I mean
like so so yeah so I think I've had my
fun in college though and now I feel
like it's time to work well you're you
know that's the [ __ ] PR version
Taylor the reality Taylor
still [ __ ] in that sewed hmm yeah
don't beat yourself up don't hold
yourself accountable to arbitrary
[ __ ] fantasies just put in work and
enjoy that enjoy eating [ __ ] and dirt
and bleeding and the grind and don't
give a [ __ ] about what anybody else
thinks why you haven't done it why are
you doing that have four jobs [ __ ]
Wendy's Walmart your side hustle work
train learn don't think you're a digital
expert just cuz you're 22 and you have
an Instagram account show me how much
[ __ ] [ __ ] you've sold with your
digital social media skills okay do you
understand no I do yeah you're just
you're just you're just completely in
the wrong game and I'm holding you on to
this because you and 99% of the people
that are watching or playing the same
game I know it's just why I wanted to
ask the questions but you I can't but
you're obviously not the only one no
you're the majority and and the massive
majority the question is you just need
to be stuck you just need to understand
the following you can trick losers
you're not tricking me good because I
want honest answers you don't need my
honest answer you know you're not
clicking yourself either none of us are
tricking ourselves I just want to remind
you that you might be able to trick your
uncle Hal and you might be able to trick
your girlfriend that was in your [ __ ]
college with you but you're not tricking
a winner when you're bullshitting got it
got it so even if you're posturing and
pandering and peeing yourself no winner
thinks you're winning yeah cuz I'm not I
know
work that's the answer to all these
questions gotta learn things do stuff
trying to sell [ __ ] learn how to make
money work all right I will
this is good awesome thank you so much
can you do me a huge favor
yeah can you email me in 30 days and
don't [ __ ] me what's your Twitter
handle for Instagram which once again
pan out that's why Instagram is at the
fabulous journey at the fabulous journey
yeah me and my whole team in the entire
vaynernation is watching
oh [ __ ] okay I'm gonna side I'm gonna
smoke you out of your [ __ ] okay
everybody's watching okay I got it
do you understand yeah I like your D
dress thank you I got ourselves not like
that answer that's the best thing you
said all [ __ ] listen slow and steady
wins the race
you're only competing with yourself okay
got it got it nobody else defines you
not me not everybody watchin that your
mom not the [ __ ] Kardashians you bat
it you can grind and be patient for 10
years every day and still be nine years
younger than me and I would trade places
with you that's how amazing having time
on your side is yeah times everything so
use it oh well good
see ya thank you you're welcome you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
emphasis young see I knew I was destined
never stop flexing what you expecting
the one day you better keep guessing no
time for resting not even a second I
gotta keep working this up a progression
whoa
eyes on the money they can never think
of